hi everyone my name is Aisha girl this
is my first time in Strange Loop it's
very exciting so I work at Autodesk 360
cloud platform as a senior software
engineer and I am a good developer
expert in angular and I'm here today to
talk to you about a little bit of data
visualization a little bit of the tools
that we are using before I start talking
about the tools I wanted to tell you a
little bit about the other organizations
that I work with because Alex Miller
strongly encouraged me to do that and
that doesn't happen very often so thank
you for the night
I've been I hosted woman who caught me
down in San Francisco for JavaScript for
two year two years and I've been
teaching for girl develop it and
preparing curriculum and it's open
source free out there and anyone can
take it and use it anywhere that you
like it's teaching material or teach
with black girls codes they have amazing
hackathons and also the last mile which
is the program in prison in San Quentin
prison in California we've been teaching
there more than a year now and I'm just
one of the mentors and I have with the
curriculum as well and it's a very very
interesting program if you are
interested there's a ten minute
documentary about it too and it's been
an amazing experience to do that because
it's a totally different thing to be
able to code in a place that there's no
internet and lastly I've been the CTO of
any cans for the lot for more than a
year last year so any cannons we teach
human trafficking survivors how to code
I was inspired by the last mile and our
success there and it's been great we had
a lot of challenges but we have great
students
so that's about the organizations that I
work with but if you have any questions
later on find me I'd love to talk about
it so why do I want to talk to you about
storytelling with your data because
that's the problem that I've been trying
to solve at work recently I mean lately
so at autodesk if you're familiar we do
a lot of treaty programs and the one of
the product that i'm working on is the
treaty viewer it's such an amazing tool
i was so you know inspired when i first
saw it
you can move around 3d things you can
pull them apart and you have a walking
ability you can just walk in it this is
such an awesome tool and it really
encourages people to work together being
able to you know work from a distance
especially like the architects and
manufacturing designers but soon enough
we realized that just being able to have
access to the data is not the whole
thing
we are able to just display any kind of
model and most of the models are so much
more complex than Golden Gate Bridge and
when you see it most of the time people
are very confused they don't know what
to do you build all these amazing tools
but then it's really hard to use so we
have to be were basically not open
source but it's an open API so anyone
can take it and put it on their own
website and people did and they did
really cool stuff with it so this is one
of them they just took it it's a
building and they just gave so much more
information than the data it has to load
so what this is doing is that the the
green things that you see there is are
the sensors so they are able to measure
all the inefficiencies of the heat and
or maybe gas I don't know what they're
measuring exactly and they can monitor
it at all time and another really cool
one that I found totally nuts
our products someone in the open source
that is actually made an animation with
it so within their rights will be read
the documentation for IKEA everyone do
that and then it's really confusing you
don't know and the pictures never look
like what it is but this is a great use
of the treaty environments I think and
it's really telling us where to look for
I mean if you just send me this model I
would never know where to find those
little stuff yeah I think I can assemble
that so these are the things that we've
been working on and struggling with a
lot and I think this is a problem with
everybody we have a lot of data we don't
know what to do there's just like
overexposure to some data but it's
really hard to understand and just
giving access to someone to the data is
not the whole picture so these are the
examples on the slides and if you want
to take a look and also the forged
Orascom is the platform you can go and
check out the API yourself and for the
tools at address at least we use three
chests obviously angularjs D tree and
rxjs and many more actually
has anyone use angular 2.0 yes
okay and you're teaching your Diner so
if you don't know it came out it's out
of beta now it came out Wednesday and
I'm super excited to be the first one to
talk about hopefully so you can check
out the new version and the new websites
here and it's a really amazing tool it's
been two years and thousands of commits
on me this is just the angular website
I mean angular repo there's so much more
and everything is organized into smaller
modules now and it's so much easier to
wrap your head around the different
parts of your application I think and
the speed and performance are improved
vastly now you don't have to ship the
compiler to your clients anymore you can
just do the compiling and do the things
that angular needs to do in the backend
and then send compiled version of its
which is 60 percent of the angular code
and there's a lot of really cool
toolings that helps us to use it angular
CLI is one of them it's kind of magical
rxjs is I think it was built by
Microsoft first but now some people in
Netflix are working on iStent these are
all open source obviously it's an
amazing tool I was so sad when I first
heard about it I why didn't I know about
this anyone used it before yeah very few
it's really really cool but it's also a
little mind-blowing at first so what it
is is that instead of our promises it
allows us to work with observables in a
very efficient way and we have the kodan
Wiser's and tight script and many more
tools and material design is in alpha
but it's looking really good so far the
other tool that recently changes d3 so
it went to a huge change as well it's
you how many people use tea tree phew
yeah
it's an amazing library truly amazing it
stands for data-driven documents it
allows you to work with your data and
make Dom manipulations very easily but
it's also a very flexible tool which
means that it's complicated to work with
sometimes so it has a new version as
well version 4 after a whole year Mike
Bostock said it's ready now it's also
organized into smaller modules so people
can just take parts of it and don't have
to have all of the library if you are
not using everything so which makes it
even better
to mix and match different libraries
because you don't have to worry that
you're using this or that it has a lot
of cool functionality than a very very
long changelogs I strongly recommended
reading it and it has an amazing
open-source community on the website you
can see all of the examples and take it
and people constantly post it and there
is a conference that there's a
conference coming up for d3 dutrey
uncomf
and they don't allow you to apply for
the conference if you don't submit a
code there so they encourage sharing so
all of these things are changing very
rapidly so how do we migrate from one to
another and there's just too many things
to migrate from and we wish it was this
easy you just change the script and then
everything works but obviously it's not
the case but the good news is that there
are lots of helpers t3 is the changes
are not that difficult to handle let's
say you need to change the some of the
functionality but the way you write your
code is basically the same that is not
the case for angular it is very
different but
what they have been trying to do is
trying to change the style of it a
little bit to make it easier for people
to make the switch and they're also
building the enna and upgrade tool so
those of you haven't seen it for d3 so
it allows us to make some selections
they are on the dom and attach some data
to it it's just like jQuery but with the
data added to it I'll say and you can
now you can do a lot of things like
whatever you want with that data points
at the dom using that data so in this
case we are selecting some paragraphs
and appending some array and we are
using that arrays elements to create our
HTML for those of you who worked with it
I actually haven't met anyone who really
worked with tea tree and hasn't had a
moment of saying like what just happened
and it usually is about our selections
and there's a lot of emphasis on it
because there's this really kind of
confusing function called enter and
append and then exit and remove and
every time you enter in depends you are
changing your selection and you are
working on a totally different selection
it was that was the case but now you are
actually getting a copy of it I think so
as I mentioned the way we work hasn't
changed that much so we still have to
anytime we have new data points we have
to make a selection append the data to
it and then append all of our Dom
elements with those data points to our
stage and when we need to remove it we
have to do a
then remove but there's an addition to
it so which is the merge function which
we did not have before which allows us
to merge the one that has to leave and
the ones that are coming in which is
really useful I mean if you're doing
real-time data or any kind of data that
is important that you show the
difference it's a really cool thing to
do have so I don't know if you could see
it but so I have the basic you know the
HTML added with my data but I have two
different data points say that one and
data to erase so I'm rendering the first
one and then rendering the second one I
don't know if you could see it but now
the ones that are leaving has a
different color than the ones that has
to stay which has a new new data points
attached to it and we are merging them
together to be able to see it at the
same time GG comes with really cool
transitions and it's even easier now to
work with them basically it's defined
for us and we have an each function and
then there's a lot of ways of doing
different easing which is really nice if
you are you want to use few things from
d3 but you don't want to get to get into
all of the SVG's and deep dive into data
visualization one thing that you can
definitely use these skills that you can
not really find in any other bank any
other library what skills does is that
takes your data point and then scale it
to the environment that you are trying
to display basically to your screen so
usually in your screen is not this big
but
it is taking everything as a range all
of your data well this is not you later
I'm sorry the range is the your display
size and then you also have to give it
the domain which is the range of your
data points and then it gives you back a
function that calculates any time you
give a data that calculates the matching
point on your screen this is not super
useful for printing but it's very useful
for axes and other stuff and actually
was a little bit more complicated before
now it's so much easy easier with d3
version 4 so we can just divide our
process into building our SVG populating
our data and then drawing our axes over
and over so we do this inside the random
function most the time because most of
time you will need to change your data
points and then redo the rendering also
you can take advantage of the animation
request frame so here's an example you
can change the data and the skills are
changing and axes are being rerender
each time we click
so why are we using angular and d3
together and has anyone use angular and
d2 together we should be friends I
really like it I think there are few
talks here - about react and d3 it is a
really great idea to put d3 functions
into a component because the tree is not
really easy to do you have to basically
define everything from your skills where
everything has to look so it's not like
a premade library I mean plug-and-play
thing so you have to create the same
things over and over so it's a really
great idea to be able to put them inside
different components with angular or
react or anything else so that you can
reuse them you can just pass them some
data it could be a bar chart could be a
scatter plot and you don't have to write
it over and over so that's why I do like
using angular 2
well angular 1 was actually doing
exactly the same thing with the
directives but it was a little bit more
confusing I realize we also have ng
modules which allows us to put together
our components and services and all of
the functionality that goes with it into
single modules this is I was really
excited about it there was some you know
people were not very happy when they
said we will have modules for some
reason there was a huge discussion right
but I think it really makes it easy to
you know move code share code and
basically make your own libraries and
typescript has been very useful because
d3 is very picky
maybe I mean when you're drawing your
line with a lot of data points all of
your data points has to be number you
know whatever you need it to be but if
any data point is missing if you have
one issue with just one day apart
your whole graph want render and type
scrip is really cool because you have a
chance to check it's the if what you're
giving to your graph is the right thing
so to get started with angular 2 angular
CLI is a really great tool I mean there
are lots of other options out there
there's a starter project but this is
really really awesome so you just have
to implement stoller globally and then
you can just say engineer my app create
a new app and then you can run a server
it will npm install everything for you
and build it and so this is the basic
structure of the app out of the angular
CLI
i have few additions here but so we have
a distribution function folder that's a
CLI created some dev assets for us and
you can build for production as well
everything is ready for you and we have
everything loaded for us and angular CLI
has its own JSON file that you could
make some adjustments and make it your
own basically once you do that on your
app you have this one main module this
is where your application starts so it's
a very tree structure thing you have
only one component that is your root
component and once you initiate that it
knows what else to render it knows it's
child components and then the child
components know it's child components so
I think it's a really cool system it
also allows you to do a lot of lazy
loading very easily so you can define a
totally different routes totally
different part of your apps separately
and then include it and it will make it
easy to work on
so here is our app module whenever I
create a new components or service
automatically CLI is adding it to my app
component this might not be the behavior
that you want sometimes but it's very
useful for now so we have the six
imports modules these are the main
angular modules at the beginning and
then I have some material and I have my
own components so if we look at the our
module structure we have some
declarations these are the components
that we are going to be using we have
some imports all of the modules that
this app will need and we have some
providers which are the services which
will be the common functionality
throughout our app so any kind of
service that you insert on the root
level will be available to you any in
any part of your application
and then our main component is the app
components and I do have things going on
in here so one thing that I want to show
you was the animations animation is a
very new troll in angular and they have
been making it very working on making it
very flexible it looks like a lot of
code this is my animation on the right
side that's being defined so I have a
trigger so I predefined it so I think
take this trigger into any kind of
components and reuse it that's why I put
it inside a separate folder and you
define the basic transitions let's say I
actually wanted to make I always want to
make a slides animation like the reveal
yes so I think I'm going to do that with
this we have a stated we are defining so
when any time the in state happens for
that components these dolls will happen
we have some transitions and then we
have some keyframe animation
capabilities as well
so if I mean you all you are going to do
is a bar chart
I think d3 is a overkill except the
scales if it's a horizontal bar chart
that makes it a little easy but if you
have this capability in your application
already some animations and then you can
basically use divs to create the same or
SVG as well so inside my app component I
have some data service that is getting
the fetching the data for me and it's
using the arcs trail observables for
HTTP so we defined observables and where
we are going to make the call inside my
service but before I subscribe it it's
not being called anywhere so there's
something to keep in mind and the cool
thing about observables is also that if
I am NOT in this component anymore it's
not in my view and if there is some
calls that I'm still waiting for to
happen and they will all die down the
unsubscribe so I'm getting this data and
then I am giving that data to my child
component so basically app component is
one of my main components so I'm trying
to keep all of my data inside kind of
like the smart components like the top
level component so the child components
don't have to know anything about the
structure of my app and they can take
any kind of data from any kind of app
any kind of diagrams and they can be
reused so this is this was a huge
problem that we faced in our previous
products there was a lot of people
working on it and then we were trying to
reuse some parts of it and it was a true
math because we were constantly change
the data to match the structure of the
components and that's definitely not the
way to do it instead
I'm keeping the data in only one place
which is kind of the parent and then I'm
passing the data in as an attribute so
these square brackets are the attributes
binding I have the app animations
component that I newly created and it
all it needs is the data that I'm giving
into it and then it will know how to
render it
if you look at the animation component
there is not much going on but also
there is no data related stuff to it
really doesn't know which application
it's in basically so the animation one
is defining these animations based the
touch animations activation and anytime
I add a new one it adds the new one not
a previous animation but it works the
way I defined it is that I put all of my
animation definitions inside another
animations function so I can share
between a lot of components and if you
look at our component definition I'm
importing that those animations and the
line that starts online that component
is the component annotation which
defines the function the class that
comes right after it as a component and
the selector is the app animation so
anytime I want to use this I use that
HTML tag we can have template URLs style
URLs or just put them in there as well
and the other thing that we can put is
the animations that we will be using so
I'm going to use fly in and out and
datum State animations
this looks a little bit confusing but
also because I try to put multiple
animations in it that's also why so I'm
defining a fly-in start and fly out done
events so every time we see a
parentheses that means an events being
emitted so we have a way of knowing
animation is done and before it starts
so I'm just console logging that do not
doing anything about it
but the fly in and out animation is
being defined as an attribute so anytime
we have the square brackets as an
attribute and when we click we're just
talking
Oh
so here is a simple bar graph component
that I prepared basically I have the
functions that I promised to you this
set up build the SVG and populate with
the data so I keep running these
functions over and over whenever a
change happens
angular also gives us these change
protections anytime anything changes on
your components which we are expecting
the data to change the changes will be
reflected and we will rerender it here
we are defining basic scaling of the X
and scaling of the Y and we have the
axis we are defining but if you notice
this set of function is not knowing
anything about the data as well so it
doesn't have the data yet the scale that
we are defining is just telling me how
to render inside the Dom but it doesn't
know the data so far when we built our
SVG we defined just the SVG which is
going to hold all of our visualization
and then we can append all of the axes
and everything and the populate function
is the one that is letting know how to
actually render it with the data so with
we are appending the data selecting all
of the bar elements and then appending
the data to it and entry and append is
adding all of our data rectangles and we
are transitioning into it and the that's
why we have to also define the domains
which is the input values of our scales
inside our populate function
I'm also using some color scales so this
is this is the data for the Syrian
refugees by division by the country so I
really wanted to show this data because
we keep talking about we keep hearing
about it but we don't really realize
what's going on and where these people
are going and it was really surprising
to see the most of them are in my home
home country basically and it's a small
country it's not that big it's smaller
than California so I decided to look at
the data in maybe different way
okay so I added these categorizations I
got this data from Wikipedia and it has
by the country the refugee count GDP
area population I mean when we hear like
people are going to another country it
doesn't really you know make sense to us
but this is the same scaling compared
with the GDP of those countries so as
you can see these countries over here
who has the most refugees are not three
richest ones in the world and this is
the area that they have it they're not
big country's leader and relative
population and GDP per capita so I
thought it was interesting to see and
one other thing that I wanted to
demonstrate although it's really hard to
see you have to scroll to see it one of
the questions that I get all the time is
that how to display complex data this is
not very complex data but people always
try to do a very you know beautiful
complex visualization and put everything
in one place and I really don't think
it's a good idea and perception is very
important and it's really important to
see the differences and to have a
different way of looking at the same
thing
so I skip some of my spice so this is
going through the generators that we
have with the angular CLI and how we can
get started and really cool thing is it
kind of opinion it so when you do energy
bills or try to deploy it tells you all
the things that you've done wrong and
all the things that you don't need it
just strips it out it's really cool and
am i doing the time oh okay all right
I'm gonna just skip through it but
there's a lot of resources on my slides
if you like to you know save it
somewhere so these are great angular of
each well let's start with the DG ones
they are really fun this is one of the
fun ones that I recently saw this is my
absolute favorites visualization so far
the person who did it is working on the
second one for a long time now so it's
really really cool
so d3 is super flexible there is no
other library that you could do things
like that I think there are a lot of
libraries they're much easier to use
though I mean if you don't need
something very complex you should not
spend your time doing it and for angular
resources there is a chrome debugger
tools it just released last week but we
already have a lot of tools we have the
CLI reality chrome debugger and we have
a lot of great courses and I think there
was one of them in this conference also
and angular 2 has some open source
charts as well they're really really
cool if you are doing something simple
again definitely use somebody else's and
it's a great learning opportunity I
think that's it for my talk thank you
for your attention thank you for
listening and if you have any
things are gonna just talk please come
say hi and I have some t-shirts I heard
3d and order desk
if anyone wants thank you
[Applause]